We've made a mistake.
That's what police in Texas are saying
after they pulled over a car
and what they thought was a high risk
traffic stop.
They approached a couple of guns
on the family, even handcuffed a child.
Frisco officers say
they ran
the cars plates
but typed in the wrong state,
leading them to believe
the car was stolen.
CNN's Camilla
Bernal walks us through
the newly released body camera video
Emma?
Erica, it was one wrong letter
that left police officers
in Frisco apologizing multiple times.
And then that apology
from the chief of police
But despite these apologies,
the family here
says they want to bring awareness
to their issue.
They want others to see
what happened to them. Here it is.
I'm then whatever happens,
we are an overwhelmed father
from the gunman myself in the rain.
And I explain to you.
Police say it was all a mistake.
I read
Arizonans on the Air
on July 23rd of Frisco, Texas,
police officer
ran plates on a black Dodge Charger.
But instead of typing air for Arkansas,
she says she typed a Z for Arizona.
The information came back
as a possible stolen car.
Police say it was a high risk
traffic stop
and at least one officer
had his weapon drawn.
Everybody in the car is outside
the window. Hands outside.
Maintain your hands outside.
Hey, find out
if there's any weapons in the car.
The family tells police
they have a gun in the car
and the car blocks and got lucky
if you reach in that car.
You make a shot.
So be careful.
Do not reach in the car.
I help anybody Okay.
Dimitri heard was behind the wheel
in the car were her husband, her son and
their nephew.
They were on their way to
a basketball tournament.
She explains what it was like
to see her sixth grade son involved.
They actually bring him in, cuff him,
and put him in the car.
They're walking him
to put him in a police car.
And I already have that.
I'm crying.
I didn't hyperventilate.
It's the way
she says they were instructed
not to move.
My husband explains to me
that my nephew is in there
literally screaming for his life
and telling him, Uncle,
we are about to die.
But finally,
he made a mistake on the play.
He ran differently.
The officer realizes it was a mistake.
They are in Arkansas.
An incident review is now underway.
I'm not justifying anything.
I'm just saying that it wasn't a computer
that read.
It was our human error that did this.
And so please forgive us.
The ongoing
review would
identify further changes
to the department's training policies
and procedures.
I thank God
that we were not physically injured,
but we have suffered a lot of mental
and emotional trauma from this.
And in his statement,
the chief of police
saying they made a mistake
and saying
the department does not hide
from those mistakes,
instead learns from those mistakes,
he says.
He spoke to the family
and understands why they are so upset.
Amara Erica,
wow. I appreciate it.